foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is
scp-1259 object class
safe
special containment procedures
scp-1259 is to be stored behind opaque
glass in a climate-controlled room in
the info Hazard wing of sine 38
scp-1259 is not to be moved or to be
removed from its case except for testing
subject to level 3 approval no Personnel
other than d-class assigned for testing
or to read scp-1259 in case of
accidental exposure affected Personnel
are to report immediately and receive
Class A amnestics
upon reading scp-1259 the affected
individual is to write or type a copy of
the text as it appears to them for
archival and comparison to current
k-class preparedness scenarios affected
individuals are to be quarantined in a
standard humanoid containment cell and
undergo regular psychiatric counseling
end of month termination of affected
d-class is indefinitely postponed for
the purposes of long-term study of
scp-1259's effect released into the
civilian population for test purposes
may be authorized at o5 discretion if so
authorized the effect an individual is
to be shadowed by Foundation security
Personnel at all times and apprehended
immediately in the event of potentially
threatening action
description
scp-1259 is a fragment of a damaged
parchment scroll measuring approximately
1.3 by 0.3 meters analysis of scp-1259
indicates that it was produced in the
1st Century BCE and that it was
originally part of a larger scroll which
to date has not been identified
scp-1259 contains text on one side in a
language which when photographed
superficially resembles ancient Hebrew
analysis of these images however
indicates that the phonograph text
consists entirely of a random
arrangement of letters incomprehensible
as a legible document
when scp-1259 is directly viewed by a
human being its text is described by the
reader as being legible in the language
which the reader is familiar with the
text described by readers of scp-1259
varies considerably between individuals
in all documented cases the text
presents itself as a prophecy regarding
the imminent Extinction of mankind as
the result of a k-class event occurring
on a specific date within three to six
months of when scp-1259 is being read in
addition to a number of Omens and
precursor events which will lead up to
said event the nature of the prophesized
event varies from reader to reader and
appears to relate directly to the
reader's personal beliefs and knowledge
of the world documented instances of the
text have included references to
religious eschatons nuclear or
biological warfare containment breaches
of ketterclass SCP objects or actions
taken by the foundation itself in no
documented instance have any of the
events prophesized in the text of
scp-1259 occurred written or typed
copies of scp-1259 texts produce no
anomalous effects and may be read safely
after reading scp-1259 the reader will
Express a belief that the text of
scp-1259 is correct and that the
prophesized k-class event will occur on
the date referred to in the text this
belief is initially expressed as a mild
concern and grows increasingly severe as
the date approaches with the reader
identifying world events or events in
their personal life including events of
a mundane or inconsequential nature as
signs or indications that the prophecy
is occurring as predicted within 7 to 12
days of the date referenced in the text
the effect an individual will come to
believe that he or she is a chosen one
who is personally responsible for
preventing the event from occurring and
will attempt to engage in Extreme
Measures to prevent the event including
political assassinations displays of
religious Faith Human Sacrifice or
to date approximately 78 percent of
affected individuals have died prior to
the date referenced in the text of
scp-1259 either due to nor as the result
of being killed in the process of
attempting to prevent the event from
occurring individuals who survive past
the scheduled date have frequently
reported symptoms of extreme depression
feelings of meaninglessness and futility
and thoughts if the affected individual
is prevented from committing during this
period and is provided with adequate
psychiatric counseling full recovery is
possible and no long-term psychological
effects have been documented subsequent
exposure of persons surviving this stage
2 scp-1259 has produced no anomalous
effect
experiment log 1259 1. date 6 23 20.
test subject
d83201 Hispanic male 38 years of age
summary of reported scp-1259 text
description of a Christian eschaton
largely similar to the depictions in the
Book of Revelation and in American
Rapture literature with the end of life
on Earth occurring on 10 3 20
cxk 3621
long-term results the 83201 requested a
Bible and a meeting with a minister and
began praying regularly in the days
leading up to 10 320 D.A 3201 frequently
entreated security personnel and other
d-class Personnel to repent their sins
following scheduled date
d83201 ceased praying discarded the
Bible and attempted four times before
succeeding on 10 12 20.
date 8 16 20 test subject
d2943 Caucasian female 27 years of age
summary reported of scp-1259 text on 9 3
20. Islamic terrorists introduce a
weaponized Airborne form of Ebola virus
into the civilian population virus
becomes pandemic by 923 Global breakdown
of society ensues followed by a
widespread rioting Warfare and famine
human extinction as the result of the
disease and subsequent chaos occurs on
12 6 20
cxk 5604
long-term results
d-2943 immediately began refusing
physical contact with all Foundation
personnel and has refused to leave her
cell since 9 17 20. the 2943 made
frequent requests for laboratory
equipment and textbooks on microbiology
insisting to staff that The Cure was
within her grasp sounds familiar
following 12 6 20 day 9403 is of the
belief that she is the last living human
being on Earth and that all Foundation
Personnel interacting with her are
hallucinatory observation ongoing
date to 12 20.
test subject d-3822 Caucasian male 23
years of age
forward
d-3822 is formally Sergeant a global
occult Coalition field operative
surrendered into Foundation custody
following security incident 2338 Psy
Omicron Delta
summary of reported scp-1259 text on 5
28 20. the GOC launches a coordinated
strike on several Foundation facilities
resulting in the assassination of the
entire o5 Council and The Escape of
several kenner-class SCP objects from
containment
current director of sites assumes
command Authority and authorizes nuclear
strikes to neutralize uncontained SCP
objects nuclear activities are mistaken
as an enemy attack on the United States
of America resulting in a brief nuclear
exchange between the United States and
in the ensuing breakdown of the
foundation chain of command procedure
110 Montauk is not conducted on schedule
resulting in on 6-3 20 cxk 209
long-term results on 5 23 20
d-3822 successfully breached containment
and escaped Foundation custody
d-3822 proceeded to report to his former
GOC post and gave a lengthy oral report
to his former Superior regarding the
foundation's weaknesses how to contain
or neutralize several SCP objects
currently in custody and the importance
of ensuring that procedure 110 Montauk
is performed on schedule intelligence
assets within GOC leadership confirm no
hostile actions are planned against the
foundation
d-3822 Superior surreptitiously issued
Class B amnestics a review of foundation
security is underway in light of the
information leak d-3822 was returned to
Foundation custody and terminated on
schedule
date 3 26 19.
test subject Dr James a Parsons
African-American male 43 years of age
forward Dr Parsons was a senior
Foundation linguist exposed to scp-1259
during initial study before its
anomalous effects became known
summary of reported scp-1259 text
identical to the English language text
of scp-1051 review of Dr Parsons
personnel file indicated he had
previously been involved in the
translation of several sections of
scp-1051 the final date in the text was
replaced with the date 6 22 19
cxk 2330
long-term results Dr Parsons made
frequent assertions that the arrival of
the Destroyers referred to in scp-1051
was imminent Dr Parsons was relieved of
Duty and committed to psychiatric
observation following an attempt to
contact several members of the o5
council to demand immediate deployment
of space-based weapons platforms on 6 18
19 Dr Parsons left his quarters and
attempted to seize control of in order
to launch a preemptive orbital defense
resulting in the deaths of 17 staff
members and security Personnel before
being apprehended and forcibly returned
to quarters Dr Parsons committed by
hanging on 6 2019 leaving us note
stating
death by my own hand is preferable to
what those bastards will do to us
okay on that extremely depressing note I
think that about does it for today
thank you all for listening if indeed
you still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaram
oh crap guy
James Saba braided Peach
fire of prime
Dr Wolf 13.
copster
worthy fire
zazapan
Irish wristwatch
signor
a la trayon
your local Foundation agent
and Lost Boy
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you
foreign